the thing that I love about his Superman
is no matter how dark or cynical the
world gets he always was hopeful in
heroic and optimistically he's a blue
sky superhero he is a man who could do
anything and he's choosing the fight
process I think every major crater at
some point wants to tell the Superman
story Krypton to me is such a vibrant
idea because there's so little that's
been explored to be a part of something
that's just got such a massive legacy to
it it's very surreal
hey everybody is Charlie DC comics and
sci-fi partnered to do a big documentary
on the Superman character the deeper
meaning of his mythos what it means in
pop culture what they're doing with it
on the TV show so I'm gonna play this be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I will be doing a video for episode one
when it airs next week so I'll remind
everybody about the schedule at the end
of the video
they just premiered the series at South
by Southwest the reviews have been
pretty good so I'm actually pretty
pumped up to check it out
hi I'm Cameron cuff from the new show
Krypton and right now I'm in Belfast
standing on our version of the fortress
of solitude
it's the 80th anniversary of Superman
and the origin of Krypton and as an
actor and fan I couldn't be more excited
to be part of this next chapter
one of the things that I wanted to do
with Man of Steel was to emphasize the
fact that Superman was an alien and so I
fought very hard to have that opening
saengmin take place on Krypton and to
depict it as a truly alien world so
while I was working on that film I
thought a lot about how we could take
things further and I approached Geoff
Johns it really started with a
conversation when David came to me and
said hey I think I have an idea about a
story on Krypton how the house eval
became the symbol of hope and optimism
it's about this character sag who's the
grandfather of Superman and it would
take place about 200 years before
Superman comes to earth Superman came
from a very sophisticated world they
were very advanced but the same time
beyond this sort of veneer of harmony
there was corruption there was
Machiavellian politics going on I think
it's something that speaks to us in our
world today I think that's the big draw
to Krypton to dive deeply into what
Krypton is and what was it like before
Superman as a baby he left that world
and the world was destroyed
the Krypton of our show is a planet that
is late in its lifecycle and resources
are so limited that there are only a
certain amount people that the
government seems to care about the
society is divided by class
it's a theocracy there's a an
authoritative ruler Rao's blessings are
bountiful but not unlimited
only his Roth seg is a son of the house
of L which has had its once proud legacy
ripped from them when CEG's grandfather
Val L miss Harris by saying that there
is something out there other than
Kryptonians rebelling against the lawful
authority of the holy sovereignty of his
eminence you are hereby sentenced to
death we need you or the house of L
you're also dealing with this symbol
what we call the glyph and what that
means and we thought it would be
interesting to subvert that expectation
and when we pick up our story in the
house of L has been maligned the
Superman symbol it's a mark of shame
your family will be stripped of all
rights and privileges you are now to be
considered righteous he grows up ranked
las' in in the rankest district which is
this crevasse that's at the bottom of
the city where people are just sort of
piled in on top of each other it's a
dog-eat-dog world Hey his mind's not
right anymore
second kid who's very angry is the world
we didn't want to start seg as the
finished package you know we didn't want
him to be Superman we didn't want him to
have all of those core values in place
right from the start we wanted that to
be the journey and we wanted that to be
a progression what the hell we think
he's back in coffee oh wow thank you
this way even though Krypton is very
much a story about the house of L and
the L lineage is also a story about the
house of Zod and his odd lineage Leiter
you are my daughter and you are result
and Zod's
are not traitors light hurts odd she's
part of the military girl she has this
relationship with the SEC which is not
allowed she shouldn't be going near a
ranked list there's so much than our
lives we can't control we still get to
define ourselves SEC is someone that she
can speak to they're really in love and
they have this really passionate
relationship but they know that it's
never going to last because they're both
bound to different people he's bound to
missa missa here is yet to be paired
with someone that's my youngest daughter
you'll be binding with her she's the
woman that sag is bound to they don't
call it marriage they call it a binding
he takes in immediate disliking to Nissa
and cheated him my father binds you to
us he is
proving that even a dreaded L can be
co-opted and brought into the fold Ness
of X is a junior magistrate of the
lawmakers guild I think a lot of missus
relationships are built on an agenda and
missus E's sake as a commodity have your
secrets and I would certainly have my
sake early on in the story receives a
call to action and this call reminds him
of the great legacy of his house of the
acts of courage and selflessness that
are so incredible than they resounds
through history but here's the kicker
they are also resound in the future so
really quick about the stranger shows up
says I'm from the future
I'm from a planet called Earth my name
is Adam Strange and I need your help to
say Krypton someone from the future is
coming to destroy Krypton why would they
do them because where I'm from your
grandson becomes the greatest hero in
the universe no one on Krypton including
say it has any awareness of Superman or
even earth at this point so Adam is the
audience's proxy this belongs to your
grandson kal-el the second Adam Strange
arrives back in time the timeline has
been irreversibly changed once his Cape
is gone our time zone Superman with him
white through existence because he's a
time traveler he shows that the show is
not just a prequel it's a story it is
indelibly linked to the present so the
events that happened in our show could
change Krypton's ultimate failure
this thing that's coming it moves from
planet to planet conquering
civilizations true name is Brainiac so
here we are in the Genesis chamber and
the cool thing about the Genesis chamber
is that it's actually a relatively new
part of the law introduced in 2014's Man
of Steel and the amazing thing to me as
a fan is that even though this franchise
has been going off 80 years the world of
Krypton is so rich there's really no end
to their creative and storytelling
possibilities I think every major
creator at some point wants to tackle
and tell the Superman story
it's American fable it's American
history everybody wants to take a crack
at it as a Superman fan there's no
greater feeling than getting the chance
to contribute something anything to the
legacy of the character it's difficult
when you're dealing with you know
character is a powerful and iconic
Superman it's it's like Sherlock Holmes
but just like with Sherlock Holmes you
can find new takes and new new
approaches that illuminate the essential
truth of the character hey guys I got
the incredible opportunity to come visit
DC Comics check out their archive and
learn more about the incredible history
of DC Comics Superman and the world of
Krypton let's go check it out so where
we're standing right now is the doorway
to the DC Comics archive is one of the
most special places in all the comic
history pretty much every single issue
DC Comics has published from 1938 to
whatever came out last week it's here in
this room everyone that's kind of
touched Superman from the radio play to
the movies to the comic books has added
to his mythology and expanded what he
can do there's so many people that have
been added to his storied is Lord it
just gets more and more refined but that
compass from Action Comics number one is
still present it's still there
it seems to me like they had the idea of
Krypton and Superman comes from here but
it wasn't a little bit later they
actually came back to it I mean it's
such a special ground for really rich
stories you can't start the story
without all this and actually I believe
I have a map of Krypton in case you get
lost I don't know what it looks like on
the show
but the rainbow cavern should be here
the volcano of gold and I can tell you
right now some of these places feature
in the show I'm not gonna tell you which
ones that's fantastic
the great thing about Superman is that
it's got a mythological basis that
everybody knows and from that you can
tell a variety of stories the mythology
has expanded so much and for us as well
it's a science fiction show so it all
has to make sense it's a matter of
bringing what you have that you think is
fresh but you have to show respect for
what the essence of the character is
this is Action Comics 236 to 247 and
it's here for a very important reason
Brainiac Brainiac Brainiac is this thing
that comes here and then captures us and
says you're just this tiny small thing
and you're never going to be important
you're never going to be big and so let
me bottle you up and take you away
brainiacs history is already tied to
Krypton even before Superman came to
earth famously brainy and came to
Krypton in the past and devastated
Kandor he stole the entire city and
shrunk it down into this globe on a ship
and so it made absolute sense that he
would be our big bad one of my favorite
interpretations of Brainiac code
throughout his is the run that Jeff and
Gary Frank did with incredible odd and
really in a way brought brainiac back
into Superman continuity and made him
who he is this incredible green being
and it's injuring to me as well the way
Brainiac has always been used as well as
for a way for Superman to re-examine
what it means to be human
Gary Frank the artist and I really
decided to take a run at making him
threatening in a I guess more horrific
way and would go around to these places
and digitize and cultures and destroy it
and just collect it and that version of
Brainiac did heavily influence what
we're doing in the show it's not just
gonna stop it Krypton
he's coming from everything it's known
as the collector of worlds
here we are in one of our oldest bounty
issues there's showcase number 17 Adam
Strange Adam Strange was really the
closest thing we had to a straight
science fiction comic book and he
transported from here to his home planet
had various adventures I come from a
planet called Earth a time centuries
from now and I've come here to warn you
the origin of atoms changes almost like
reversal of the Superman origin change
came from Earth and ended up on a
strange planet that he became the hero
of Adam strange should be our cutie
audience that this is more than just
about the Superman mythology if you go
to comic books Doomsday's origins happen
on Krypton and we'll be wrapping
doomsday into the story there's an item
called the black mercy it shows up in a
pilot and that's related to a character
named Mongol that we hope to bring in
there's a world on a conference called
thanagar where Hawkman and Hawk Holman
are from and they're going to be wrapped
up in distort as well so Adam Strange is
sort of the gateway to all the space
related characters in the DC Universe so
hopefully that gives you some more
background on the series some of the
more space-based DC characters they're
planning on doing like Hawkman Hawk
world Rand thanagar along with doomsday
Mongol all the really big stuff that you
would want them to do in a Superman
theme TV show but it's premiering March
21st on the Sci Fi Channel at 9 p.m.
it's a 9:00 p.m. show if you don't watch
television on TV they do stream the
episodes on their website and you know
you find it pretty much anywhere else
you would watch a TV show from the
sci-fi channel so if you live outside of
the United States and you're not sure
where it's airing just check the
internet you will be able to find it
somewhere on the Internet so my episode
1 video posting next Wednesday so no
worries while you wait for everything
click here to learn about how they're
doing Red Hood Jason taught on the
Titans TV show and click here for a
brand new flash thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]